RECENTLY, I'VE BEEN TROLLED
BY THIS ONE PERSON
WHO IS ON ME DAY AND NIGHT.
I GOT TWEETS LIKE THIS...
"I USED TO BELIEVE
IN FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
THEN I WATCHED HANNIBAL BURESS
DO STAND-UP COMEDY."
[ LAUGHTER ]
HERE'S ANOTHER ONE.
"HANNIBAL BURESS
SHOULD KILL HIMSELF
BECAUSE HE HAS NO TALENT EXCEPT
FOR BEING A SQUINTY [BLEEP]"
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND THIS ONE REALLY HURT.
"YOU'RE LIKE A LESS FUNNY
TAVIS SMILEY."
I HATE BEING COMPARED
TO TAVIS SMILEY.
I THINK I'M WAY FUNNIER
THAN TAVIS SMILEY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
THAT WAS THE BREAKING POINT
FOR ME.
I COULDN'T TAKE IT ANYMORE.
SO I GOT THE COMEDY CENTRAL
I.T. DEPARTMENT
TO TRACK DOWN THE I.P. ADDRESS
OF THIS PERSON.
FROM THAT, I WAS ABLE
TO FIND OUT WHERE THEY LIVE,
AND IT WAS ON.
HERE'S THE TAPE.
WANT TO TALK
A LOT OF TRASH ONLINE,
BUT THEY NEVER WANT
TO SAY ANYTHING TO YOUR FACE.
[BLEEP] THAT [BLEEP] MAN.
YEESH.
THAT CAR LOOK LIKE
IT WENT THROUGH
THE STREET FIGHTER BONUS ROUND.
YIKES.
OH, LOOK AT THIS HOUSE.
I CAN SEE WHY THIS PERSON'S
SO ANGRY.
[ KNOCKS ON DOOR ]
[ KEYBOARD CLACKING ]
HEY!
AMY SCHUMER!
WHY WOULD YOU DO THIS?
YOU TROLLING ME?
NO.
NOPE.
THEN WHO SAID,
"HANNIBAL IS SUCH A STRONG NAME
FOR A WEAK ACT"?
NO, I DIDN'T.
YOU WAS JUST MOUTHING ALONG.
AMY, WHY WOULD YOU DO --
I THOUGHT WE WERE FRIENDS!
NO ONE'S FRIENDS IN COMEDY,
HANNIBAL!
WAKE UP.
WE'RE TOO SELF-INVOLVED.
WE CAN'T HAVE FRIENDS.
THERE'S --
AMY, THERE'S NO FLIES.
NO, THERE'S FLIES HERE.
YOU JUST -- YOU CAN'T SEE THEM,
BUT YOU CAN HEAR THEM.
I THINK YOU NEED
TO SEE A THERAPIST.
I DON'T NEED TO GO TO THERAPY.
I'M FINE.
YOU OBVIOUSLY --
LOOK, I WEIGH 160 POUNDS,
AND I CAN CATCH A DICK
WHENEVER I WANT.
WHY DO YOU KEEP SAYING THAT?
YOU KEEP SAYING THAT.
[ MUFFLED ] IT'S TRUE.
WHY DO YOU EVEN HAVE TIME
TO DO THIS?
DON'T YOU HAVE A MOVIE COMING
OUT NEXT WEEK OR SOMETHING?
YES!
I HAVE A MOVIE COMING OUT.
IT'S GONNA BE RELEASED
JULY 17TH TO A THEATER NEAR YOU,
BUT THAT DOESN'T MATTER.
[ WHISPERS ]
PLEASE SEE IT.
THAT'S NOT
WHAT THIS IS ABOUT!
THIS IS ABOUT YOU TRYING
TO MOVE IN ON MY TERRITORY.
I'M NOT TRYING TO MOVE IN
ON YOUR TERRITORY.
COMEDY CENTRAL'S MY NETWORK.
-NO.
-YES!
IT'S OWNED BY VIACOM!
-WE CAN'T BOTH HAVE TV SHOWS.
-YES, WE CAN.
I WANT PEOPLE TO WATCH MY SHOW,
NOT YOUR SHOW.
THERE'S OTHER SHOWS
ON COMEDY CENTRAL.
SO WHAT? NOBODY WATCHES
TWO TELEVISION SHOWS.
LOTS OF PEOPLE WATCH
TWO TELEVISION SHOWS!
NAME ONE PERSON THAT WATCHES
HANNIBAL BURESS!
WHAT TWO TELEVISION SHOWS
DO YOU WATCH?
"EXTREME COUPONING"
AND "EXTREME COUPONING:
DALLAS EDITION."
THERE'S A DALLAS EDITION?
THERE'S A DALLAS EDITION
OF "EXTREME COUPONING."
IT'S BETTER?
IT'S JUST MORE SPECIFIC
AND LOCALIZED.
I LIKE THAT PART OF IT.
GOD!
THERE'S NO FLIES, AMY.
PULL IT TOGETHER!
THERE'S MONEY FOR EVERYBODY
OUT HERE.
I GOT [BLEEP]
I WANT TO BUY.
[ VOICE BREAKING ]
I'M SORRY.
IT'S OKAY.
I THINK A LOT OF WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING IS PROBABLY TRUE.
[ SNIFFLES ]
AND I FEEL REALLY BAD ABOUT IT.
FROM WHAT IT SOUNDS LIKE,
YOU'RE NOT REALLY ANGRY AT ME.
YOU'RE MAD AT YOURSELF
AND YOU HAVE SOME...DEMONS --
NOT BIG DEMONS,
BUT MAYBE SMALL DEMONS.
[ NORMAL VOICE ]
I'VE GOT BIG DEMONS.
YOU'VE GOT BIG DEMONS?
I'M NOT WEARING A BRA,
BUT, I MEAN,
THEY'RE -- THEY'RE BIG.
OKAY.
SO, YOU JUST HAVE SOME STUFF
GOING ON INSIDE OF YOU
THAT YOU'RE DEALING WITH,
AND IT'S NOT
REALLY PERSONAL ABOUT ME.
SO, I ACCEPT YOUR APOLOGY.
[ CRYING ]
UM, ALL RIGHT.
SO, WE'RE -- WE'RE GOOD?
YEAH.
CONGRATULATIONS
ON THE MOVIE.
UH, YOU STILL WANT
TO GRAB LUNCH ON WEDNESDAY?
[ SNIFFLES ]
YEAH, FOR SURE.
COOL.
COULD YOU PICK ME UP?
MY CAR EXPLODED.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]